hello folks have a little trouble there
with my sound welcome to rational
science
you only said on the internet that does
physics rationally everybody else does
mathematical physics
math magics
uh all the physical interpretations are
irrational all of them uh related to uh
invisible intangible
phenomena
anyways we're going to be answering some
questions at the end of the show we're
going to talk about
um the multi-universe what is the
Multiverse universe
but let's get on with the uh with our
extension segment and what we say here
is that we have the last generation of
humans on Earth because we say that it's
related to the fact that our global
economy is going to collapse and there's
nothing we can do about it so it's not
an if it's a when
um but there are some Trends what I call
what we can call megatrends that are
happening at you know I just want to
share with you so that you take them for
whatever you want them to take them with
and here let me give you a rundown
uh we have an inevitable decline in
population growth rate and this is a
steady decline that's been happening
since 1963.
um we we can't stop it and this is
worldwide so it's not just one country
or another in general population all
over the world is
um
uh the the population growth rate really
is uh becoming smaller and smaller and
smaller so that means at some point
we're going to reach a what is known as
zero population growth and we're not
going to grow anymore
[Music]
um
economic modes we've had uh
hunter-gatherers we were for most of our
ex our existence and we moved into
agriculture maybe 10 000 between 10 and
20 000 years ago moved into industry
manufacturing some countries at least uh
about 300 200 years ago and then we got
into services today the mode of the
earth is moving in the direction from
industry from manufacturing into
services
within services
we're moving from manual services to
internet services and what this
um
shows is that you know we're in the
business of this is where the jobs are
being created the the new companies Etc
what we're what we're doing is moving
into the entertainment and the ad uh
business it's just ads and uh
entertainment
um so there's I think there's no doubt
in my mind at least that the global
economy will collapse will crash okay
some point if we throw the nukes it's
just gonna happen a lot faster okay
hopefully they don't do that so that we
can live a little longer
and uh meanwhile some other trends like
loss of genetic diversity and I think
that's uh a big one uh biologically
speaking and I think that's the main
trigger for autism and the alphabet
people you know that we have today we
have a lot of these people coming out of
the wombs female wounds and it's because
all of us you know we've we've exhausted
our genetic uh pull uh we're not very
different anymore anyone you marry today
is either your brother or your sister
from a biological point of view
uh but there are some other trends that
we got to look at and it's what's
happening in physics and that's also
something that maybe you should think
about because all we have uh at least in
the last 100 years is irrational
explanations all we have are irrational
explanations uh there's not a single one
that you can sink your teeth into and
here I just mentioned a couple uh grabby
bro b
they say they drag space-time around
with the Earth is dragging space time
around itself
now what sense does that make well
this is total uh
irrationality and I'm being kind with my
language
um you know it makes no sense whatsoever
to say that you drag space-time around
or that gravity is the warping of time
you know what physical interpretation is
that and people might say well you know
that's uh euphemism uh whatever for or
an analogy or whatever they want to call
it for the mathematical
measurements and equations etc etc
we don't care we don't care what it is
tell us
what is actually happening that's that's
what people want to know out there they
don't want an equation they don't want
you to tell them telling them that time
was warped
this is nonsense this is poppycock is
this this if this is the best that the
mathematicians can do uh well all we can
say is that they're not scientists
they're not physicists okay they can do
whatever math they want in their dark
basements but when they come out here
out of their caves they have to tell us
how this universe works and if they
cannot tell us how this universe works
because they've given up on that like uh
was his name
um
Richard Feynman said that they've given
up on that well then they're not
physicists that means that all they're
doing now is just math
and then you have uh you know these
people NASA want to go want to go to
Mars
and the question is why are we going to
Mars isn't that kind of irrational to
to go to a planet that what are we going
to do are we going to conquer the planet
uh claim it for the queen of Spain
um are we going to colonize are we just
running a project there where we study
something come back
we plan to live there do we plan to
evacuate the Earth what's the point of
going to Mars
you know and here I showed the other day
uh these are some of the projects this
came out uh last week it says one year
on Mars NASA analog astronauts begin
mock red planet Mission today and you
can watch it live in other words they're
doing what uh what's called Biosphere 2
in Arizona where they put some people
for one year in a an enclosure to see
how they cope so that they can prepare
for the trip to Mars uh you know they'll
be putting other people in there okay
this is more or less what the trip to
Mars is going to look like you know
we're just going to take the little
rocket ship and take it all the way to
Mars some people are going to descend
some people are going to stay under a
rocket then they're gonna come back
and that'll be the first mission
supposedly you know it's going to be
kind of like what they did with the moon
you know they send someone up there then
comes back but you know we never
colonized the moon are we going to
colonize Mars
and by Colony I mean you know are we
talking about this this is this is
what's uh out there in the plans okay
you can see they're planning on building
cities out there
uh working the mines
is it is this ever going to happen or is
this just dreams that people have
and assuming it does happen uh you know
what's what's the uh Point uh what are
we trying to do here what's the what's
the goal is it to get out of the planet
or something
you know
so uh
I hope I'm still on there uh
I had a little trouble earlier so I'm
just wondering I'm still on let me know
uh if uh everything's all right out
there okay and I'll continue
anyways the point here is that
um there's no purpose of going to Mars
and
and um if there's no purpose of going to
Mars why are we spending all this money
you know in in all this space
exploration if it's for military
purposes you know developing technology
no problem I can understand that one but
just to go to Mars to actually settle
and colonize like these people are
indicating there do they really believe
that's going to happen
or is that is almost as
uh much fantasy as uh you know dragging
space time around
frame dragging
and then uh again all the irrational
physical interpretations that should
that we see today I mean
isn't this a sign that we're at the end
of the road in some way that we have all
these irrational physical
interpretations coming from people who
who took courses at the University who
have phds who are professionals uh in
mathematical physics if you can call it
physics at all and they come up with the
most irrational physical interpretations
you can imagine and people just swallow
it
every single one every single Theory
that's out there they can tell them
anything they can tell them that Angels
move the Earth around and they'll
believe it too because the mathematician
said it you know like kind of like
um maybe in the third fourth Century A.D
where the monks would go out there and
tell the uh flocks the only people who
could read the Bible where the monks or
the priests and so the only guy who
could read in the village was the priest
and he could tell him anything they
wanted people would have to believe him
because he told them what the Bible was
saying you know and this is more or less
the same there's a group of people a
relatively small percentage of the
population that is uh knows uh all this
advanced math
and that's fine but when they come back
uh what do they tell us you know that
space is Warped that's what gravity is
that Earth drags space-time around and
so on
and so the question is are these even
worse than the priests of the fifth
century you know I mean who are these
people are they worth anything or is it
worth listening to them why are so many
thousands and even hundreds of thousands
even millions in some cases of people
watching them and listening to them it's
like if people you know want to get
their shot of science for the week and
they say oh I'm going to listen to Brian
Greene or to Michio Kaku or one of those
guys right because I want to see you
know what's new out there in science
and these people come back with the
biggest idiocy that you can imagine
and they believe only on the basis of
authority okay and here you have some
examples okay I collected a couple just
some of the most prominent ones okay I
haven't collected them all but you can
see where I'm going with all this here
you have brain green and he says a
particle can be at two places at once
you know the slit experiment they never
figure that one out so they had to
figure out the most irrational physical
interpretation they can find for that
you know and there are people who
swallow a lot of that stuff and then
your parent or use the same language
and it's like they're just imitating you
passing it uh you know uh to spreading
it out you know just just uh
regurgitating it here's one fellow he
says the father says the double slit
experiment provides no evidence for
Consciousness causing collapse of the
wave function but it also provides no
evidence against it
this this is really funny because
um
a fellow is saying what you're saying uh
it's causing the collapse of the wave
function but it also has no evidence
against it you know uh the collapse of
the wave function you cannot cause it
with consciousness
okay
um sort of you know you don't even have
to think about that
and uh again I want to make sure uh
everybody's online can you all see me
and hear me I hope so
uh please someone let me know okay
okay thank you
I wasn't seeing any comments there thank
you okay
um so uh yeah the question here is does
this make any sense to say that
Consciousness collapses a function
what can that possibly mean they just
take all these uh cliches right from
mathematics mathematical physics it's
really mathematics and uh and they just
say oh yeah the collapse of the wave
function and I did it with Consciousness
and then they're looking for proof for
evidence what sense does any of that
make
you know I mean Jesus
here's uh another uh famous guy who
tells us the following is uh Guru in uh
black holes and he believes that you
know there are black holes because he's
dead now but he believed in black holes
he was the king of black holes and what
is a black hole we talked about that uh
a couple weeks ago and that was what a
Zero Dimensional nothing
and they say that this Zero Dimensional
nothing moves Stars around
and people just accept it on the basis
of authority because someone told them
you know that that's what happens out
there despite that they can't see they
can't touch
the black hole they can you can't touch
a singularity singular just swallowed
all the matter
it's just a bunch of mass no matter even
though mass is defined as the quantity
of matter or measure of the quantity of
matter so there's no matter but there's
Mass
there's no elephant but the tons are
still there you know
so you know I mean what sense does any
of this mean here's another value
and he talks about wormholes you know uh
how to get to to another Universe I
guess everybody wants to escape the not
only the planet or the solar system they
want to escape the universe the entire
universe let's go somewhere else
that's what it seems like at least
uh another valve uh also famous here
Larry Krause and he says he talks about
dark matter
so what is dark matter well dark matter
is that stuff that the mathematicians
had to pour under equations you know
around a Galaxy to make the uh equations
match what the astronomers are observing
out there so it's a variable that's how
it is and now they're pointing their
their Scopes trying to detect uh dark
matter which is invisible intangible
just like black holes all this stuff is
invisible and intangible and nobody says
anything about that everybody criticizes
in my robe says hey it's invisible
intangible uh yeah but the cheaper to
think about the fact that black holes
and wormholes and all this other stuff
that you know in the dark matter Dark
Energy all that's invisible and
intangible
and they say well we're gonna
find it indirectly by the effects
that all this stuff has on visible
matter
that's that's the only thing they've got
and I guess they're going to be doing
this for the next million years
yeah this has to give you an idea that
we're at the end of the Rope as far as
humanity is concerned concerned because
uh we're at the end of the Rope
in just about everything not and among
other things you know physics the fact
that these people have not never figured
out how this universe works and we're
all about to expire here and these
people are still trying to figure out
what gravity
they can't even figure out magnetism so
you think about all this this is the end
of the Rope for
um physics for mathematical physics
after 400 years of trying you know since
the days of Galileo and Newton all the
way to today they have not figured it
out despite all the experiments that
they ran despite all the equations
and a lot of them will tell you well
we'll never figure it out because um
father Universe talks a different
language than we do and blah blah blah
and it's the fourth dimension and we're
in the third and all that kind of
nonsense
okay here's another fellow and his uh
name is Hansen Johansen he's on BS
some call it PBS I call it just BS and
he says nothing is a lot and as always I
hope you learned something
and he took uh several minutes to show
you that he cannot he doesn't know what
nothing is he never defined a word
nothing
and this is important because we're
going to be bringing this subject now in
um in the context of the Multiverse okay
so what did this guy Hansen do well he
just talked a lot about nothing
um you know trying to figure out what
nothing is uh I guess he's it's a
a definition that escapes him that
eludes him and he's not the only one
here's another fellow his name is
um Neil Tyson and he's also uh talking
about nothing in one of his uh shows and
neither one of these fellows you know uh
could figure it out what is nothing and
all they could do is just go through the
motions of trying to figure out you know
by elimination whether you can achieve
nothingness
not not whether you know what
nothingness is or what nothing is
because if you know if you say I lost a
penny well what is a penny and he said
the guy tells you well look it's a
little round uh you know plate blah blah
blah and you say okay I know what to
look for now but when you say nothing uh
what do you look for
how can you look for nothing but these
people try to search for Nothing by
eliminating all the somethings from a
given volume and uh here you have them
these two clowns okay and they're in the
science of nothing you say Bill you're
insulting them you're treating them
wrong
and no no I'm I'm not insulting them and
I'm stating a fact I'm not you know I'm
not making fun of them or at all I'm
saying I'm saying what is these people
are clowns all of them they're clowns
why and uh because they're not in the
they're not in into science they're not
into physics
they're into the entertainment business
you know they're there to make you laugh
to say oh I got my shadow science this
week and now I know a lot more than I
did last week
and all they're giving you is ignorance
and if you take them seriously well then
you're a fool if but if you laugh at
them they're just clowns and they're
just in there for entertainment and
they're in there for their own careers
you know they're no longer physicists or
or into that subject matter they are
coached by people from Hollywood or from
wherever and all they do is shows where
they try to popularize what the
mathematicians are struggling to
understand which is how this universe
works and of course all they can do is
give you
the most irrational explanations they
can find that's why they are clowns they
are Waterville comedians okay don't take
them for anything more than that because
they they will not give you any
interpretation physical interpretation
about how this universe works they
cannot tell you what electricity is they
cannot tell you what magnetism is they
still cannot tell you what light is they
cannot tell you what gravity is what can
they tell you that
well that well again that the Earth
drags space around itself or time around
itself
what is that what kind of nonsense is
that it should click in their mind that
something has to be definitely wrong uh
you know these people no longer have
their feet on the Earth
and um
so here uh this is how these two fellows
you know they both essentially went
through the same um
steps
and they said look math invented zero
you know you have five minus five you
get zero you have nothing you know
that's that's a uh mathematical
transaction right operation uh zero is
equivalent to nothing right so now we
have a def a mathematical definition you
could say of nothing it's zero whatever
that means okay you have uh why because
you subtract it in other words you took
five apples from five apples you have
nothing is that the definition of
nothing is that absolutely nothing I
mean for the purposes of physics okay
and uh so you know they say no such
thing as nothing outside of math you
only can have nothing in math five minus
five ten minus ten that kind of thing
but you cannot have nothing
in physics right
so it turns out that you know they're
missing half of the words
important words in physics because you
know the universe we said the other day
was what things and nothing some things
and nothings
and some things they haven't defined
very well uh we can say that but let's
concede that but they say they don't
know what nothing is or that there is no
such thing as nothing for the purposes
of physics meaning that they only have
half a half the universe they only have
the something
they don't know anything about nothing
okay
anyways they go through this uh
I guess you could call it a thought
experiment you have a box okay you open
it is there nothing in there well we all
know there's air in there we go we feel
something in it we call that air a bunch
of molecules okay so we remove the air
from the box somehow okay
is there nothing there well they say you
can't remove
all the molecules all the atoms from the
box even if you put it under you know
with vacuum pumps and pump it out in a
sealed a sealed container right even if
you take it to the Moon to space
wherever you cannot pump every atom out
of there okay so that's one issue the
other issue is that you they say you
have electromagnetic energy in there you
know uh some kind of thing and what is
energy what is this electromagnetic
energy they think of it as a bunch of
particles because it's mediated by
photons which are waves and all that
stuff is in there particles waves the
whole shebang okay photons so you can't
get rid of that
and the question is you know uh so you
you can never have nothing you can never
have in a complete vacuum which is I
guess what you would call a nothing
right
and they say look even if you were to
pull everything out you have virtual
particles coming in from the void
constantly so fast
you know they come in and out so fast
they do that so fast that you can't even
measure it
so even when you have absolutely nothing
meaning no particles no photons no
energy no whatever no Fields you still
have these particles coming in from the
void
on their own I guess they just pop in
and out constantly and so you always
have something in there whether you know
it or not
and then uh if that all fails you know
you can go between two galaxies and say
well is there absolutely nothing between
two galaxies I mean here you have you
know
billions of light years perhaps and
nothing in between we could say nothing
right is there absolutely nothing there
and they say even there you have
uh particles of you know very few but
you still have something in any volume
of space
and so they say and nevertheless you
have thoughts and actions and so on and
those are something anyways you can't
get rid of that you can't get rid of
anything of everything that's in your
box that you took out there wherever you
want however you pumped it down you
can't get rid of everything that was in
there no matter what you do okay and so
uh they conclude that uh even nothing is
something
so if all else fails they win that one
too okay so there is no such thing as
nothing because everything is something
and that should give you an idea why
they never figured out what space is
because space is nothing space itself
okay
uh aside from the energy aside from the
particles aside from all this other
stuff that the waves uh particles
whatever they want to put in there if we
take all that out we have something else
separate from all that garbage and
that's called Nothing space is nothing
what is nothing well it's very simple
nothing is that which has no shape if
something is that which has shape
nothing is its antithesis and that's uh
that which has no shape very easy they
should have figured that a long time ago
and they should have started with
definitions so they they could carry out
a rational conversation okay
okay and uh leading to the subject
matter today here you have one fellow
his name is uh Sean Carroll and he says
the Multiverse is real and so one of the
questions we're going to have is whether
you know Multiverse means many universes
and the question is what separates them
nothing what's between them nothing and
if it's nothing meaning space
uh do we have one universe or many
universes because remember Universe was
what
matter and space
and if space is nothing
and that's what's between two universes
there's nothing mess
uh then and each Universe shares the
same space because I'm not sure you
could isolate that space uh somehow you
know put a fence around it of some kind
uh then do we have one universe or many
universes do we have a universe or a
Multiverse right so that's the issue and
just in case we have another fellow also
famous okay his name is uh Max techmark
and he comes up with several types of
um
multiverses he's got the level one the
level two he's got several level twos in
fact uh he's got a level three and a
level four and you say what is all this
about well you can see there uh he says
uh what is the infinite Universe uh you
just uh Multiverse I mean uh you just
have all these uh new multiverses these
new universes which are created every
second
um you have uh the brain Multiverse
which is the one uh that uh proposed by
string theory and you have uh inflation
Multiverse you know every time
um uh for every second that there is uh
you have more and more universes and so
you have a it's like a bubble Creator a
machine that creates bubbles every
bubble is a new universe with matter in
it and space and time and the whole
works energy okay
um you have the quantum uh many worlds
okay uh uh so uh
what that one is really weird because it
says that if uh if there is another
Universe you will find that you're in
that universe as well as in this one and
you're in all these multiple universes
every time you take a step you are in
different universes at the same time and
in each one you have a different history
okay so this is what the mathematicians
concluded after 400 years of thinking so
hard and doing their equations and all
that nonsense okay
and uh and then you have the
mathematical Multiverse you know and he
says uh
tecmar says that
the only way you can really
conceptualize it is mathematically there
is no Multiverse outside of math okay
and so what does that have to do with
physics absolutely nothing so they had
to create this Multiverse uh to give
some work to some of these so-called
physicists mathematical physicists
because
they had nothing to do they can't find
dark matter with their telescope they
can't find black holes with their dollar
Scopes or their you know other equipment
they have different kinds of equipment
to sense all these things they can't
detect it they can only detect it
supposedly indirectly through visible
matter okay and we explained that uh
there there is a different explanation
for what they call black hole dark
matter all that stuff and we'll get into
that later in in
for Duran down the road but uh the point
is they can't see or touch any of that
stuff so they said well they created
this Multiverse and what is that that's
just a mathematical thing that says hey
you know you have all these different uh
lines that you can take your life can
take they get into more of philosophy or
religion really than they do into
physics and this is the way they're
handling all this stuff and the question
is does doesn't this give you an idea
that we're at the end of the line when
they can't you know have a solution to
things to Simple Things I mean we're
forget about all the you know the black
holes all that stuff that he has out
there that happens out there in the
cosmos
uh please explain gravity you know why
does this pencil fall to the floor
that's all I want to know you know you
need to bring Dark Matter into the
picture do you need to bring black holes
just to explain why the pencil fell to
the floor
uh magnetism you know you have a when
magnet attracts the other
very simple do we need uh black holes
and all this other stuff that they've
invented that we need multi uh universes
for it and many universes
and so it has to give you an idea that
something is terribly wrong
if for the last hundred years they've
been trying to give us quantum mechanics
general relativity String Theory lately
right the last 50 60 years uh
and they still can't answer the simple
questions we're not asking them to
answer you know what's happening out
there in space where you can't see very
well you know with your telescopes it's
far away you can't touch it Etc no no
just tell me where the pencil fell to
the floor that's all I want to know you
know please explain the mechanism okay
and that's where we're at we haven't
been made a single dent in the world of
science science physics you know physics
a branch of science they have made a
dent in physics because they can't
answer the simplest of all questions
and uh there's many reasons for that
among them no definitions they never
Define any important term related to
physics okay uh
uh they've got all these mathematical
Concepts that's what they use as
mediators and that's any rationality
they're alone and then they simulate
everything with particles with discrete
particles which ain't particles anyways
because the so-called particles uh used
in quantum mechanics are actually
equations uh
just motion just the concentrations of
mass or charge that moves
you know when you say what's moving well
it's a number
of value that's what's moving and so you
know of course when you have nonsense as
your foundation you cannot explain
anything and that's where they're at
today
but it the in relation to you know our
standing or uh
or you know where do we stand with
respect to Extinction should give you an
idea that it's just another clue that
I'm throwing in there that we're very
close to extinction okay uh together
with the other things that I mentioned
such as you know the alphabet people
autism and loss of genetic diversity and
so many other things and the fact that
you know there's no future in economics
as well I mean you know what are we
going to do for the next million years
do Services entertainment ads
so uh just pitch in now physics as well
or mathematical physics mathematics as
we call it
okay let's move on to the Multiverse
here and uh what is that Multiverse well
we gave you a little hint just now but
let's continue here we have uh this is
what it looks like this is what they
imagine a bunch of uh balls a bunch of
balloons okay
and the big question here you know that
you're going to have to answer is you
know what's the black stuff that
separates all these balls what's inside
each ball
okay now uh this is not really a correct
uh vision of that because this is how
they visualize our universe or at least
our visible Universe they say it looks
more or less like this uh this is what
they mapped out there okay okay and
um
if you put this in the right context you
have to put it also in terms of the Big
Bang which looks more or less like this
okay you have the big bang the history
of uh our universe and when you take a
snapshot of the last one right
uh what you're really doing is
um is taking a cross-section of time
across section of of motion which is
location all you have is every atom and
it's it was separate from all others at
a given distance from everything else so
they're all just separated by you know a
little uh
by distance and so what you have is that
last uh sheet uh and you got to think of
it as a two-dimensional thing because
it's a cross section right it's a
three-dimensional photograph of God
right but everything's standing still so
it's a Gods movie it's a
three-dimensional uh
frame each frame is three-dimensional in
in God's movie in this Universal movie
okay so this is what you got to look uh
think about as far as the universe each
Universe has its history and uh so maybe
this is what uh the Multiverse looks
like really you know all these
um
W Maps Okay uh one at a given distance
from another and again the question is
you know what separates them okay
if we were to put it in the Universal
movie right standing still because they
don't have to be moving we can take a
snapshot there you see it it's it
occupies a single frame okay and
remember that frame is three-dimensional
okay so that means that
um you're using God's camera okay you
took a snapshot of the universe every
atom wherever it is and if you take uh
that whole thing and you say there's
another Universe fine no problem but
then the question is what's the black
stuff that separates every one of these
okay that's that's the big question
if especially when each one of those
universes includes space okay because uh
well you have here uh let's let's go
with the questions here here's the
question okay definition of Universe you
need to First Define what a universe is
if you're going to talk about the
Multiverse so you got to start with the
universe and
and to
um so-called mathematical physicists you
know mathematicians they didn't Define
the word nothing to begin with they
should have started with a definition of
nothing then they can talk about nothing
but no they started at something and
they worked their way towards nothing
saying let's take things out of the box
and we'll end up with nothing and they
say well you can't take everything out
of the box and so they said well there
can't be any nothing in the end that was
their conclusion but they never defined
what nothing is okay
we don't we still don't know what it is
and so the first question is what is a
universe you know and are there other
universes out there
okay if so what separates one Universe
from the other and then uh is there any
object anything that can isolate two
universes
okay
that's the question and more
specifically you know can you separate
can you put offense to space
can you put a fence around space and say
okay space stops here and we don't know
what continues don't we don't even have
to worry too much about that the
question can you put a fence around it
and say this is the end of space
okay because if you can't do that that
means that other bit of matter is
sharing the same space as our universe
meaning is it a different Universe if
universe is space and matter
okay that's the issue all right
okay so let's begin with the definition
well we tried the last week uh they put
in there this these are the definitions
you'll find out there and they put
energy in there they put time they put
everything they can think of you know uh
even your experiences they call that
part of the universe okay and so you
know energy time uh
every content Planet Stars Galaxy
obviously right matter and space
they put everything in there and they
say universe is everything
even what you do
in other words the history the motions
the in that not not only the present but
everything in the past is also part of
the universe and a lot of people include
almost everyone out there includes also
the future
so we don't have a good definition of
what the universe is and it's very hard
to talk about the multi-universe you
know multi-universe if we do not know
what universe is what it means what the
word means what does the universe mean
and so what they tell you is usually
what uh what the universe is comprised
of okay
and
give me a second here
I don't know what happened here
anyways uh one of my things doesn't work
for some reason I have no idea away
okay anyways
um we have all these um people that we
covered last week people like uh Stephen
Hawking and he said that
um this this was his notion of the
universe he says
um the universe is space-time and
space-time is an event uh all the points
that make up space time and every point
is an event means something that happens
at every point and if you take the sum
of the aggregate of that you end up with
uh what is what space time is and so you
have to think of this as all these dots
in motion because each dot is an event
and so I guess this is the best picture
we can you know concoct from uh from
what uh good old Stephen told us okay
I'm not sure what sense any of that
makes uh from what came out of his mouth
because he's saying that
you know uh a DOT a point
which is just an object right static
object you would put it in the Universal
movie you would put it in a single frame
and he says it's happening it's
something that occurs
so he's putting a verb in there and he's
representing it with a DOT
so who knows what all that means okay
from a physical point of view
and then you have here uh another
version which is the uh gravity waves
that we covered last week and yeah what
you see is uh what are those waves I
mean what what are those things and they
say well it's energy well what is energy
energy is a concept a mathematical
concept what's that got to do with
physics what are we staring at what have
they Illustrated okay so that's the
question there and so yeah you can
illustrate anything you want and say
energy well show me energy bring it to
the conference put it on the table so we
know what energy is before you move it
I need to see a picture of energy I need
to see a mock-up uh something standing
still then you can move it later on and
of course you can't do that with energy
because energy is a mathematical concept
but see that's what they're doing here
they're showing you all these vibrations
they sense of energy
it's the waves
wave is not a physical object wave is a
verb what is wavy
see you gotta stop it first and take a
snapshot of it and say this is this is
what is waving this is energy this is a
field
and you can't do that with any of them
okay because all these words are already
in motion they embody motion
and here you have uh the famous uh Dark
Matter okay the and dark energy of which
the universe is made so the real matter
the one we can see the Luminous man is
just very small percentage not luminous
matter is about 3.6 percent and the rest
is all dark matter dark energy and just
in case they put in their black hole and
wormholes you know they have all this
stuff in there and they say uh this is
this is what uh the universe is
comprised of so we have all these
versions because we have if the universe
is is you know made of Dark Matter Dark
Energy Right a lot of them 90 right 90
plus percent then uh and it's all
invisible right and intangible obviously
so it gives the mathematicians or the
astronomers at least a lot uh job
security they have a long time to find
something that doesn't exist out there
right so they they can do a lot of work
for nothing right but the question is if
if if our universe is made up of all
this stuff then what is the what is
waving what are the waves
you know when they say there's a gravity
wave coming through the universe and
what are we talking about are we you
know what is is that dark matter that's
vibrating is it dark energy that's
vibrating
and what is dark matter what is dark
energy when they say well we don't know
what it is and they fix it with that
saying we don't know we're just looking
for it
and uh and then you have how does how do
you put that together with the with
Hawking's you know points
so we have these points that all the
universe is made of points right
that that's a little different than uh
What uh the Dark Matter Dark Energy
world says and that's different than
what the uh people who say you know
waves are and Fields and energy so we
have like these Street camps
and it's like you know you can't you
can't uh reconcile one with the other
that's the problem
okay so I don't know this is these are
one of some of the things that we had to
look at
okay and um
so here we have again this is the
question we need to answer we need to
answer what's the dark stuff that
separates all these universes especially
when the dark stuff is inside each one
of those Universe because otherwise
you're saying what the that space that
dark stuff is not inside each one of
those universes
you see the problem
that's where the problem is so you you
cannot say that space is outside and
serving as a cocoon as a shell for the
universe because space is inside the
universe as well that means that that
universe is sharing the same space that
this other universe is sharing
if they're all sharing the same space
because you can't put a fence on space
then what the hell is this
multi-universe how can you say that
there is another Universe if they're
sharing the same space
if universe is matter and space aside
from all the other stuff that the
mathematicians put in there and this is
the issue
okay and uh here we have it uh this is
uh what these other two folks uh went
through and they said look in the end
there's no such thing as nothing and so
uh you know the question is if we have
nothing out there
uh how how do you put a fence around
nothing how do you prevent someone from
Crossing from nothing into whatever into
thought because you can't be into
something it's got to be into something
else that is not nothing or something
and so you know again uh
where they're lost to understand first
the definition of the word universe and
second to find out what separates each
one of these universes that's where
we're heading so how do we do it in
science well in science physics right
branch of science
um we start with the foundations of
physics
and Foundations means you're going to
Define your terms
okay you're going to Define them
scientifically what is the scientific
definition well you see one there it
says limitation placed on the extent or
usage of a word okay that's what a
scientific definition is about you
should be able to use it consistently
rationally
scientifically okay
and the first two words you want to
really Define is something and nothing
you know what is something now it's a
shape what is nothing now it doesn't
have shade see how easy it was
so we have two these two words are
antonyms okay and we have synonyms there
uh for something we have object thing
anything body you know there's several
and for nothing we have a couple there
space vacuum nothingness void
okay so we have synonyms you can't use
those to define the word nothing
you have to Define nothing and nothing
is that which doesn't have shape okay
very simple one has shape the other one
doesn't they're antonyms now we can use
them consistently rationally
scientifically
and there we have some other words
concept okay distance location
exist and motion where it exists are
very important because physics is the
science of existence physics tries to
elucidate or try to explain right by
making assumptions of what exists
and what is uh existence physical
presence in other words an object that
has location
okay so that's where we start that's our
starting point
and once we have the definitions in
place now we can use them to speak and
to make ourselves understood people can
understand because they have relatively
simple definitions few words the fewer
the words the more crisp your definition
the less uh The Devil's Advocate can
destroy from your definition so always
make your definitions as short as
possible and they never learn that
anyways uh you look at all the
definitions of mathematics uh science
what is physics oh they have paragraphs
uh any little piece that you can take
out you just destroyed their definition
life you know words like life they
cannot Define obviously because they
have all these words
it takes a paragraph to define the word
life
okay so here we have the universal movie
uh
and where are we gonna put Universe well
we said that last week we said it's just
matter in space okay so all those little
dots they could be galaxies uh Galaxies
have stars and planets and so on but
every one of those is made of atoms in
the end everything is atoms okay so all
we have is matter and space
okay that's that's our universe
okay and people say where's energy well
energy is a little weird uh uh here
we'll we'll show you energy for the
first time in your life if you've never
seen energy here it is uh drummer
okay here it goes there we have it
mathematical physics says that
everything is discrete particles just
moving around and whether it's uh space
time or quantum mechanics even strain
theory it's all made of particles
ultimately uh rope hypothesis there's a
single thread in the entire universe and
that's all there is just one thread
okay uh see how simple it is and how
different it is okay so you don't have
to believe in it uh we're just asking
you to accept the Assumption because
this is what we're going to use to
explain everything from Gravity to
electromagnetism including magnetism and
electricity and functioning of the atom
okay okay so that's our starting point
um here's uh what this produces in the
case of quantum wall you have is
discrete particles in the case of the
Rope model well we have that all atoms
are physically connected they're all
interconnected okay and so we have
um
essentially hydrogen atoms that's what
we're going to look at
uh just about everything in the universe
is 90 you would say is hydrogen atoms
maybe around close to 10 percent is uh
helium so that's the universe in a
nutshell and the one percent is maybe
all the rest of the matter that's out
there but what we're saying is all
hydrogen atoms are interconnected okay
and they're connected by that thread
that uh you just saw and that thread
turns into every uh atom which turns
into a rope that connects DNA like rope
that connects any two atoms which
continues and to another atom and uh and
so on so forth so the thread itself is
the one that converts from atoms to rope
from rope to atom and so on the line
eternally the whole universe is just
that that's how simple our universe is
okay and then what you have uh higher
elements are simply more hydrogen atoms
bunched together that's all it is
together with neutrons which is another
issue okay okay so we end up with our
interconnected Universe it looks
something like that okay
so this would be our universe and you
can see the black stuff there that's
called space or nothing and yeah we have
to put a frame around it just because I
have to put you know stop it at some
point is that you is a space infinite
and the answer is no only objects can be
infinite uh nothing cannot be infinite
okay the word infinite came from
mathematics mathematics and so they said
hey we can count forever and that means
that the universe is forever or space is
forever or whatever the way we look at
it in physics we don't use math we just
say look space is nothing it has no
shape that means that you know
um matter is finite at some point and
you know you can go to the last bit of
matter in the universe but you cannot go
to the edge of space because space has
no edges no borders no surface
okay spaces uh the opposite of what
mathematics uses for space which is you
know a ball they always say it's a bond
they tell you well we don't know what's
outside the ball what's giving shape to
the ball because we've never been there
we can't be there so it's an
unscientific question
no this is a question of physics not a
philosophy it's a question of physics
you have to tell us
what surrounds space if you're going to
give space a uh form a shape and because
you turned it into an object you turned
it into a thing you turned it into
something instead of nothing
so yeah we have a problem with that
because space is nothing no shape it has
no uh no surface no no perimeter or
whatever uh and that's the opposite of
an object which has shape period we're
done
okay that's how simple it is so we don't
have to worry about what's outside of
space giving it shape because space has
no shape And it's very hard for people
to you know put their brains around that
okay
okay so let's find out what happens
um
if we try to leave our universe you know
what if you wanted to travel to the last
bit of matter okay that's what we're
going to be doing now to see if we can
get to another Universe okay because
this is about the Multiverse right okay
so here's our universe okay this is our
starting point
okay and uh let's say
um you want to travel outside the Earth
okay and the first thing outside the
universe but before that you know you
have to consider the fact that our
universe is all interconnected all the
atoms according to the Rope model all
atoms are connected okay now I didn't
draw all the connections there okay so
some people are going to say hey but
we're all the gazillions of connections
no no uh I didn't draw all the
connections just imagine that every atom
is connected that's what I'm trying to
uh illustrate there okay and now
um let's say let's say we put God into
the picture you know God created the
universe okay so let's let's put God in
there okay
and so the question is you know uh does
God exist
and there are different ways of
answering this question so you know what
did we say exist was well it was an
object that has location well it looks
like God has location at least with
respect to the universe here right I
think it's straightforward but as you
can see God is not connected to our
universe uh let's connect them
and we're just going to connect one atom
of God we're going to assume God is a
physical object he's made out of atoms
and he exists why because you know uh he
has distance with respect to every atom
in our universe and
um
and he's connected by ropes okay but the
question is if if the ropes weren't
there okay if we have this situation
again right does he exist
and that's a question of definitions you
know and I think that if we are going to
find a word exists as an object that has
location we can still say there's
distance between God and the universe
therefore God exists by definition
because uh we don't we do not need the
ropes in order for God to exist we just
need distance we need location which is
the set of distances and in this case
every atom in God's body has distance
with respect to every atom in the
universe but you can see what would
happen if um if God is really connected
to our universe right if we all share
the same single thread
well the farther he goes the more skewed
our universe becomes is you know he's
pulling all those threads from from our
universe so you know that would really
have an effect on us if if he was able
to do that right
so keep that in mind as well the further
God goes you know uh the more he threat
he pulls out from our universe and this
has something to do with you know us
traveling outside of our universe under
the Rope model
you know you're going to be pulling
ropes
the farther you go and the farther you
go the more skewed that whole picture is
going to look here's the universe out
there little ball that you can see you
know bird's eye you can see it far away
and you're out there in the middle of
nowhere close to no matter right because
you're leaving the universe you just
left the last bit of matter behind you
so you're kind of stretching those ropes
more and more and more the farther you
go
and uh so are you drawing all that rope
from the thread of the universe yes of
course that's what you would be doing if
you attempted that right if you could
achieve it right
okay so here we have our universe again
okay and uh here we're gonna try to
leave the the universe okay here we go
give me a second here there you go
okay you're gonna try to leave the
universe
okay take your spaceship and you can see
what's happening to the ropes you're
pulling those from the universe okay the
farther you go of course uh this is not
the scale to your ship is not that big
but you can see what I'm trying to
illustrate here you're you're leaving
with your spaceship and but you're
connected to every atom in in our
universe and so there you know you
finally are in the middle of space let's
say right maybe you're still traveling
but uh we'll just say that you just
stood still in space we took a snapshot
of you okay this is where you're at now
okay
um what happens if there is another
universe and you're going in in its
direction or somewhere
okay so here's here's the two universes
now okay we have two universes and uh
we're gonna have our spaceship again
okay you're gonna leave the Earth I'm
sorry our uh our universe okay and
you're gonna head outwards
and the question is you know
um here you have another universe so so
now you have a different situation
because uh you could be in in the first
case you had gravity only behind you but
now you could have gravity in front of
you because gravity is the number of
ropes right that are uh you know the
closer you get to our universe the more
the ropes fan out and the more gravity
you will feel and here you're running in
the opposite direction so you have less
and less gravity As you move out but now
you have a universe in front of you that
you know could be tugging on you but uh
but when you know like you know here you
are in between the two universes right
and the question is if if
um there are two situations what is that
you know you could uh have this
situation where
um uh that Universe every rope in that
Universe every atom in that universe is
connected also to our universe therefore
it's also connected to every atom in
your spaceship okay that's one
possibility okay and um we have a
different
scenario here here you have you know
these two universes are isolated from
each other that means that
um you know all the ropes in our
universe are connected among them and uh
the ropes in the other one are connected
kid among them but none of those ropes
are connected to any other the atoms in
our universe
so you have this other Universe which
might be bigger maybe uh if it's bigger
and none of the ropes are connected to
our universe it could be that uh for
example light it has a different speed
because our universe the speed of light
has to do with the thread and the number
of atoms out there you know in the
universe if we have more
um a rope more thread in that other
Universe could it be that light travels
faster or slower or whatever
you know we don't know that but that's
something you got to think about but the
question is you know you have these two
situations one is where the two
universes are isolated and here the two
universes are connected
well if they're connected uh I don't
even think we can talk about two
universes because first of all they both
share the same space and in this case uh
they share the same ropes the energy
right that the mathematicians talk about
those are the ropes and we have torsions
moving along the ropes that's why we can
see Andromeda or anything for that
matter and so we would be able to see
this other Universe because every atom
there is connected to our eye to the
atoms in our eye but in this case we
would not be able to see that other
Universe because none of the ropes of
that Universe are connected to our eyes
so that universe as big as it is is
invisible to us
we can't see it because we can only see
through the ropes torsions along the
ropes is light and you know also gravity
for that matter but the point here is we
would not be able to see that Universe
in this situation and it would not have
any gravitational effect over us because
as you can see gravity has to do with
the ropes and there are no ropes of that
Universe connected to our spaceship
okay so it creates different scenarios
okay that you have to ponder under the
Rope model when you talk about the
Multiverse this is one and here is the
second one there okay those are the two
scenarios but you can see that uh in
either case they're sharing the same
space
and what is Universe universes matter in
so we have a situation where we need a
new definition
uh we can't talk about the word Universe
because the universe is everything and
if they meaning space and matter and or
Oaks in this case energy if they you
want to use the word energy okay we're
talking about the ropes we're talking
about the atoms we're talking about uh
the fact that the space right so we have
two chunks of or clumps of matter
and maybe that's what we have to call
them we can't we can call them Universe
because universe is everything that
includes space here they're sharing the
same space we can't put a defense on
space so there's only one universe
there's only one Universe there can't be
any Multiverse there could be different
clumps of matter
and if there are two different clumps of
matter the equi the question there is
whether they're connected or not whether
the two universes are connected the
atoms of the two universes are connected
or not if they're connected it's uh like
what we see today you know it's our
universe but if they're not connected
then you can talk about two clumps of
matter not two universes but two clumps
whatever you want to call them I call
them clumps you can use that word if you
want
say that Bill Gates created okay so we
have two clumps of matter
and not universes because when we use
the universe in that context we are
misleading you know people and they say
oh there's many universes no there's
only one Universe because we all share
the same space we cannot
put a fence on space so we all share the
same space there can only be one
Universe there could be different clumps
and the clumps include you know
um planets gases Stars galaxies the
whole works okay so that's where you got
to look at it
okay once I'll ask a question in
relation to that and so I wanted to
answer him says if by physical existence
we mean has location and shape
and the answer is you already failed
see people put words into my definitions
and uh they want to change some of the
words that means they didn't understand
squat okay they're not paying attention
they they think well it's the same thing
like one guy uh change and says what is
a what is an object says that he didn't
like the word shape so he put the word
surface
no no it's that surface it's shape okay
it's not surface surface is a 3D concept
shape applies to both 2D and 3D and
objects are both 2D and 3D so you cannot
use the word surface to define the word
object but people are not careful
careful enough with their definitions
and they think well it looks the same to
me you know and so it's not shape okay
the word is object thing okay something
okay you can use those so exist is
object thing
anything everything something right plus
location
here we got that don't change the word
object don't don't put the word shape in
there and say well I'll rephrase it no
no don't rephrase anything we every
letter has to be right in the right
place there okay it's when you change
something as you get into trouble
because you think you said the same
thing you haven't okay shape is a an
adjective
let me repeat that shape is an adjective
for the purposes of physics
okay it's a property of an object
there is no object that stands alone
called shape okay shape is a property of
an object and so you cannot say the
shape did this the shape did that now
the object did this did that shape is a
property of the object okay so if it's a
property it's called an adjective in
physics in ordinary speech something off
they speak a irrational language we here
we speak only rational language okay
shape is a concept known as an adjective
and location is specific to this rope
connection okay
if there are if there were two separate
rope uh Loops then they never interact
okay so I guess he's talking about like
you know uh two universes where you know
the the ropes are not connected from
that Universe to our universe any atom
there is connected to any of ours that's
what he's saying so the question is
whether they interact whether they can
go through each other well again uh this
is speculation you can all speculate you
can speculate both ways the best way of
doing it is making an assumption and
that's what we do we make an assumption
in one case where they do across each
other and the other where they don't and
they say well what happens in one case
what happens in the other case because
that answers is next uh question or his
next concern he says it would make sense
to ask how these rope Loops are located
relative to each other as they have no
rope connections between them
and again uh a lot of wording but make
it simple you know this is the issue
here is if the the atoms of one Universe
are not connected to the atoms of
Another Universe
uh candle ropes cross each other you can
make an assumption both ways and then
explain something with that assumption
and likewise if the two Universe across
each other you know one goes right
through the other we can't see them if
they're not connected right because we
can't see that which is not connected to
our eye right through the ropes so the
question is would an atom of that
Universe crash against an atom of our
universe with these two universes
Collide With the Stars of each Universe
collide
I would think so but again that's a
question of assumption I mean you're
taking all this to a point where you're
speculating a lot and there's no problem
with speculating doing thought
experiments but then the only issue here
is you make an assumption you say let us
assume
that they do Collide or let us assume
that they go right through each other
you can make whatever assumption you
want in these cases because you're doing
a thought experiment in which you're
maybe trying to explain something you
know or just having fun trying to find
out what would be the consequences fine
you know that's that's all it is okay
but
um
we're more concerned about what's in our
world and that's why we use the rope
model to explain things that happen you
know in our everyday lives like
electricity and magnetism gravity and so
on uh functioning of the atom
okay uh another fellow asks the question
here this is uh from the comments that
people made this week says is there a
test for rationality other than asking
you Bill
okay let's uh answer this fellow yeah
here's here's your answer hopefully I
can give you an answer and it is yeah
you have to Define what the word
irrational is once you define the word
irrational uh you know what rational is
and what irrational ain't you know or
and all you have to do is just follow
the definitions and you'll find out if
you have a rational Theory or not and
the main point in irrationality is when
you move Concepts around like
mathematicians do they move fields and
they move waves and they move charge
they move
um what uh wave field charge uh Black
Holes Zero Dimensional
singularities they move energy
they move forwards they carry the force
they carry interactions on their back
they transfer energy they transfer
information how do you transfer
information I mean by the teaspoons you
carry it on a horse I mean I don't know
how they transfer information so yeah
when you when you use Concepts
and uh you use them as physical objects
that's known as irrational
and all of mathematical physics is
irrational
in relation in relation to
um invisible and intangible mediators
okay that's that's where they run into
trouble everything visible we've already
figured out you know how about of course
pulls a cart when we know that stuff you
know
visible stuff easy stuff it's the
invisible stuff that drives them nuts
and partly because they simulated all
with particles but there you have a your
answer the answer is that irrational is
when you move Concepts which is what
mathematic mathematics
mathematics does mathematical physics is
mathematics because they do you know
witchcraft they'd use
um
you know Concepts as mediators that's
where the problem is and that's why they
don't have any rational explanation for
anything uh then you have inconsistent
use of definitions or undefined words uh
theory is inconsistent with the
assumptions right with a hypothesis uh
describing and claiming to have
explained they don't know the difference
between a description and an explanation
and I think that an explanation is a
bunch of descriptions that's what
they've been taught and they just pair
it they never thought about it
and then uh the mechanism proposed
doesn't work or cannot be even imagined
you know like uh gravity what is that
warp time
uh yeah try to imagine that one for me
you know if you're if you're smart
enough so yeah if you cannot even
imagine what you're saying you know when
when uh guy like Stephen Hawking says
that don't try to even imagine
space-time
but he's going to explain his theory of
gravity based on space time and say that
what that the Earth drags space time
around
you know that's when uh you know you
need another beer
okay another fellow says
you make a clear distinction between
ordinary speech and scientific speech
yeah okay but you are still using words
kansa okay so
what do you what you are claiming is in
fact that some existing concepts are not
properly understood
as their definitions were perverted no
that's not what I'm saying at all okay
I'm I'm not saying that they're uh
misunderstood uh what we have is we
don't have definitions nobody ever
defined the key words especially that
little lady there miss Ayn Rand Ein Rand
okay in Rand never defined a single word
scientifically and that's why she ran
into trouble that's why all her
conclusions of physics okay not her
politics not her religion we don't care
about that nonsense we care about only
physics all her conclusions regarding
physics whether she knows or not that
she stepped over the line into physics
that's a separate issue but all her
conclusions were reflective physics are
irration although why because she never
defined the two key words which is the
word object which he called entity okay
and the word exists when she had no clue
what that word meant and we're going to
go over that real quick here uh he says
basically you're in agreement with Rand
and I don't think so no Iran it was the
same thing as
um all the others uh you name him
wittenstein uh Russell
um
what is it uh
Emmanuel Kant David Hume Plato Aristotle
they were all the same they never
figured out the definition of the word
object and they never figured out the
definition of the word exist okay and
that's where the problem is they never
figured out those two strategic
definitions
and those two words belong to physics
exclusively it doesn't belong to
philosophy to ontology to all that
nonsense that we've been doing for the
last three thousand four thousand years
now those two words belong exclusively
to physics anyone using the word object
in any way shape or form the word exists
in any way shape or form has stepped the
line over into physics whether they know
it or not and now they are in the realm
of physics they have to abide by
rationality of physics okay anyways uh
it says you this uh once you discover
that your concept of shape is nothing
else than Iran's concept of identity
so identity is shape see these people
are mentally that's what they
are they they they want to impose
something which ain't true okay no no
shape is not identity okay in fact uh
you have this uh ridiculous thing called
The Law of identity you know mental
retards created that okay that a is
equal to a
I hope it you know how many how many
beers do you need to come up with such
nonsense yeah they have this law of
identity it's the law it's a fall of
identity I guess God created this law
existence exists oh I love it existence
exists and that's this is the kind of
language they use and they don't even
realize it okay and for the objects that
can be identified within it by means of
Consciousness no absolutely not all of
it is garbage all of what you just said
is nonsense papika irrationality and let
me tell you why uh we'll get to Ayn Rand
here and she'll speak for us okay uh
we'll see what she had to say about the
entity
which is what her word for object but
it's okay we don't care we use the word
entity as well as a synonym of object no
problem there and what you had to say
about exist and this is it this comes
from her books okay okay so here it is
to exist is to be something
okay something whatever something is
okay but uh something is empathy so
she's going to make those synonyms
cognition starts with the ability to
what
what did she say perceive things
entities of man's five cognitive senses
what is she talking about perceive
perception and sense right sense
perception right touching seeing hearing
you know only to provide them with a
direct awareness of entities sight and
touch
she said the same thing as David Hume
she said the same thing as Emmanuel can
she said the same thing as every
so-called philosopher none of which were
philosophers okay they were not
philosophers philosophers something else
philosophy is something else and so uh
she was thinking of seeing touch
that's her definition that was her
notion let's get it straight
Ayn Rand thought that an object is that
which you can see or touch that's
essentially what she said I'm going to
show you in a second even more evidence
in that in that regards something makes
sounds
talking about senses something tastes
sweet talking about sentences something
smells fresh okay so he's talking about
senses right but in order to perceive
this something he needs what sight and
or touch
so what did she mention five senses okay
she mentioned touch sight Etc
the concept entity meaning thing right
an object whatever she wants to call it
Anthony no problem it is implicitly the
start of man's conceptual development
and the building block of the his entire
conceptual structure It Is by what
perceiving entities that man perceives
the universe
she thought an object is that which you
perceive through the senses that's not
what an object is
she did not say that an object is shaped
and I don't know what that word identity
is we clean our nose holes with it you
know especially the law of identity I
love that one love identity but here's
uh here's good old Lane uh what she says
about uh she says a little more she
clarifies just in case you missed it
right here it is an entity means what
self-sufficient form of existence now
entity in existence are not uh synonyms
which is the problem that human can't
couldn't figure out they said what does
the word exist add to the word entity
just to use her terminology and they
said we can't figure it out the word
entity didn't exists mean exactly the
same thing and this is what she says
here as well she's saying enter the
existence are the same in fact she
defined entity in terms of existence
as against equality and action a
relationship in other words verbs okay
an entity is a thing great yeah all she
said is a synonym
um but here it is an entity is the
primary sense is a in a in the primary
sense is a solid thing with a definite
boundary yeah uh it can't be a solid
thing with a different definite boundary
because A square has a boundary but it's
not very solid okay that's why that
definition she never figured out that
you know what the definition of the word
object the word entity is okay as
against a fluid she says that air is not
a thing
she's saying that air which is made out
of atoms is not a thing but uh uh if we
go with her boundary definition a square
is a thing so there you have it the only
reason a square is not a thing according
to her definition is because it's not a
solid but air which you can touch right
uh she says it's not a thing because
it's a fluid
in a literal sense air is not an entity
okay there are contexts such as when the
wind moves as one Mass when you can call
it that by analogy but in primary sense
fluids are not entities okay so she says
that gases and fluids uh you know
liquids they're not they're not things
they're not objects
and again she goes into perceptual okay
so uh and there you have the reference
so no in Rand never figured out the two
words that she had to figure out which
were the word object the word exist
and that's why she was an atheist
because she never figured out the word
exist
see if she would have figured out the
word exists she wouldn't have said she
wouldn't have been an Atheist she would
have been a scientist
atheists are religious folk why because
they talk about belief
they talk about non-belief and disbelief
and they try to turn it around twist it
in every way they possibly can and they
will always end up with the word belief
because uh forever everybody
defined uh exist in terms of the word
belief and they said no no it's
knowledge and knowledge is just a
synonym of belief so we haven't changed
anything uh belief and knowledge are sin
and imperfect synonyms uh knowledge is
just a stronger belief that's all
knowledge is but your knowledge is not
the same as my knowledge okay and so
your belief is not the same as my belief
and so on so now you can't use the word
knowledge the word belief
um to define the word exists exist is
that which an object that has location
okay and she never figured that out okay
so no in Rand uh
then contribute anything to physics okay
and the words object that exists belong
only exclusively to physics
okay and here's uh non-file says ever
since the dawn of philosophy all the way
to mathematics they just been recreating
The Ether just with another name
absolutely there is a hundred or more
ether theories as of today yeah they all
deal with either way because
they don't know what's out there and
they call that whatever that that
ignorance they call it ether
they ask The Ether okay they fixed it
you know and they either does this The
Ether does that it waves it shakes it
does all these things it blows your
house down but we don't know what the
ether is and you ask them what is the
ether is it a thing or not
if it's a thing draw it take a snapshot
or or you know bring a mock up to the
conference so we know what the ether is
and if it's a concept Define it tell us
what is the definition of this fantastic
word uh you know I mean what are we
talking about is it like uh Forest many
trees many atoms many particles is that
what the ether is okay so you got to
Define it or take a picture of it
you decide which if you're going to use
it as an object you gotta take a picture
okay you have to show us and also
identify what surrounds it okay
because you can say uh you know that's
what the ether looks like it looks like
a dog okay fine I need to know what's
outside the dog you got to identify that
entity that Medium whatever you want to
call it that's you give me that shape
that's giving it contrast okay oh it's
actually mine that allows the existence
of all objects somehow it's the platonic
either it's the news it's the uh logos
it's the hegelian self-thinking thought
and it's the space time yeah they
they've he's totally right they've used
it for everything they use it as a joker
in a rummy game you know you can put it
anywhere you want once you use the word
ether just like the word energy the word
field you can put it anywhere you want
because you know nobody knows what those
words mean and and they're all Concepts
but they use them as uh physical objects
as paddles you know uh field is a
concept you know and so is energy but
they say oh the field moved the charge
yeah sure
uh charges 1.6 times send the minus 19
coulomb so you move the number with a
field which is what a bunch of numbers
uh in a volume of space is that what a
field is
so yeah you can't you can't use these
words as physical object which is what
mathematical physics has been doing for
the last 400 years
and here's uh just in case you know this
Father Robert Laughlin he's a Nobel
Prize and he stands behind what this
fellow says he says the modern concept
of the vacuum of space confirmed every
day by experiment is a relativistic
ether okay
but he says but we do not call it this
because it is taboo
yeah you don't say space time is ether
because they'll kick you out of the club
but that's what space time is it's a
bunch of particles which is what uh
Stephen Hawking said you know it's a
bunch of points what's upon an event
so we have all these events all these
points and they Shake around
and that space time which is exactly
what uh the Greeks thought of The Ether
what is it was The Ether it was that
invisible air because that's what ether
means air it's just a different you know
the quintessential it's a different type
of air the air of the Gods you know so
to speak the one that they can see and
touch and whatever and smell and so on
we we have no access to that ether right
and so they had all these particles
moving around and then that's what the
mathematicians of the 19th century said
hey that's waving it's moving up and
down and you know and that's it's The
Ether
so what is an ether a bunch of particles
is it an ocean uh is a Sandbox what are
you talking about you know can you draw
a picture and until you do you haven't
said anything
anyways we'll